i have a pet peeve i hate the term soft
skills
um there's nothing soft about them you
know and when we talk about hard skills
and soft skills as if they're in
opposition to each other
that they're which is nonsense it's hard
skills and human skills
hard skills are the the skills i need to
do my job and human skills are the
skills i need to be a better human being
and it's the skills of it's being and
human skills
are the skills that make better leaders
and you're 100 right
so i had the opportunity to spend time
with the navy seals which is a very high
performing organization
and i spent time at the head of training
for the navy seals
and they have an elite group within the
navy seals um
and i asked him how do you choose who
gets into that elite group
and he drew up on a graph on a piece of
paper
uh an x y axis performance
versus trust and the way they define
performance is the way we define
performance do you hit your numbers it's
all the stuff that we're used to
measuring
right the way they define uh
trust is what kind of person are you um
they wait the way they put it is i may
trust you with my life but do i trust
you with my money or my wife
i mean their seals anyway what he was
explaining to me
is that uh uh clearly uh
nobody wants uh nobody wants the low
performer of low trust
down here clearly nobody wants that
person right clearly everybody wants the
high performer of high trust
of course that's what everybody wants
what they what they learned is that the
high performer of low
trust is a toxic team member and they
would actually rather have a medium
performer of high trust
sometimes even a low performer of high
trust it's a relative scale
over the high performer of low trust
now if you think about it in business we
have a million metrics to measure
someone's performance
and we have negligible to zero metrics
to measure someone's trustworthiness
and so we accidentally keep promoting
toxic team members to become toxic
leaders
who are driven by self-interest
predominantly um
and are not uh uh people who we
necessarily trust we may like them we
may get along with them but we don't
trust them
um uh uh the amazing thing
is it's unbelievably easy to identify
these people in a team
just go ask any team who the [ __ ] is
and they'll all point to the same person
easy right likewise it's actually very
easy to identify
the high trust employees go ask any team
member
who on your team who on your team
will always be there for you when the
chips are down you trust them
more than anybody you want to be more
like them and they embody the values of
the company better than anybody
they'll also all point to the same
person and that person may not be your
best individual performer
but they are actually one of your best
natural leaders who are getting
uh higher performance and greater morale
out of everybody else
and yet they're completely ignored
inside the organization very often
because we don't have a system to
recognize and reward them
and so i'm a big fan of peer reviews i
think peer reviews are a fantastic way
to identify um some of the
the people who really do build great
organizations uh who are great leaders
inside our teams
um so yeah you're a hundred percent
right um
uh we we do a very very bad job
of of of identifying people who have
some of these
other attributes these human skills and
human skills include things like
listening
empathy patience uh how to how to have
difficult conversations
how to have effective confrontations you
know we work with people who when they
want to give us hard feedback
it's like they they hurt they hurt us
you know
as opposed to helping us um there are
difficult conversations the rise of
black lives matter in the united states
and in other places i think is a very
is a very good example where there's a
lot of
team leaders who did nothing not because
they're bad people it's because they
didn't know how to have the conversation
because nobody taught them
how to have difficult conversations we
have to teach
human skills if we want people to learn
how to be better leaders
we don't teach people how to lead we
promote people
who have high performance and then we
expect them to know how to lead
which is nonsense you know you know when
sometimes
you're in finance for example somebody
taught you finance they taught you how
to
read a p l if they didn't teach you how
to do it you wouldn't know how to do it
and it's the practice that made you good
at your job and then all of a sudden
just because you happen to be good at
that job
we promote you to a position where
you're now responsible for the
the people who do the job you used to do
but we don't teach you how to do your
new job
we just expect people to know how to
lead because you're good at finance
doesn't mean you're good at leading a
finance
organization they are completely
separate skill sets
and so we have i think most companies
are desperately lacking
in teaching leadership quite frankly
they have a two-day off site including a
day of golf
you know they hire speakers like me and
you know and that's it they think that's
leadership training i mean those things
are important
but that's not leadership training you
need real curricula
inside your company you need mentors and
teachers and metrics
to measure things like listening empathy
you get you get it
right if you teach it people will know
how to do it